bonjour j écoute merci d'être avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france alors chaque
jour son lot de révélations depuis lundi
et les révélations de ce scandale à
pegasus une entreprise qui aurait des
liens étroits avec le gouvernement
israélien est ce que c'est une affaire
dans sa globalité qui vous étonne
non c'est là dit ça existe dans la
plupart des pays notamment les pays dans
lesquels on est la france et il y a le
problème grec et en france aux états
unis suite à des accords semblables line
législation législation très stricte qui
n'est pas appliquée en israël et il y a
bien sûr une inspection et un accord
gouvernemental pour toutes
exploit rotation des produits
sécuritaires notamment notamment les
armes et les commerces dans des armes
bien sûr il est très développé dans le
monde entier
il semble que la législation et
israéliens dans le sujet n'est pas assez
fort même s'il ya chacun et chaque
chaque deal est examinée
approuvé par les gouvernements israélien
et rappelons que kate en 2013 et une
affaire beaucoup plus grave a éclaté et
30 la chancelière merkel et le président
hollande d'ailleurs on était espionné et
par l'agencé de sécurité par l agence
informatique américaine et par un essor
c'est lé nez ça y est
et c'est un très grand scandale bien sûr
des protestations etc mais qui est tombé
à l'eau
les problèmes que dans l'état actuel des
choses dans le monde et tous ces marchés
là est très réglementée et il faut y
penser
et parce qu'il s'agit aussi d'armes il
s'agit pas donc été de d'armes qui tue
directement mais bien sûr quand on vend
des logiciels et à des gouvernements
afin qu'ils procèdent pour la sécurité
de l'état et contre le terrorisme et à
des différentes définitions l'essai du
terrorisme pour l'un les terroristes
pour 1
[Musique]
et
ce qui pour l'heure il n'est pas pour
l'autre j'étais là avec vous couper
quelques quelques instants vous parliez
à l'instant où tout à l'heure des du
gouvernement il règne qui n'a pas réagi
depuis le début du scandale lundi
dernier comment justement interprété ce
silence de la part du gouvernement
israélien
il y avait une réaction que vous avez
donné des musées la défense gagne c'est
bien comité interministériel et qui a
été nommé mais c'est à dire gouvernement
on ne peut pas et réagir et directement
ne l'aurais pas fait la france et dans
les cabinets ses cabinets à dépenser
réunis parce que naissait il s'agit
d'une société privée donc depuis un
début de réaction
la seule qui peut l'être et c'est que le
gouvernement a une certaine politique et
en la matière dans la matière de la
défense et qu'il veut à son application
est ce qu'il a vraiment veiller à
l'application donc ça on le saura pas on
ne saura jamais exactement de
gouvernement ne réagisse pas bien sûr et
si à une henin problème avéré est ici
pour l'instant il n'est pas vrai que
cette fameuse liste et cette fameuse
liste à a en effet servi et ae
à mettre sur courtois suivre et les
portes rddc numéro téléphone
est ce que par exemple les services de
sécurité marocains ont suivi leurs
propres droits parce qu'ils étaient
aussi sur la liste voyait donc la
question se pose aussi
qu'est ce que c'est que cette liste et
qui n'est probablement qu'une première
étape
vis-à-vis des suivis éventuelles et
parlait de d ces logiciels ils n'ont
très rapidement avant d'avancer
avant de se quitter vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure la du scandale de l'espionnage
de la msa un nouveau scandale
d'espionnage
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est encore
possible d'avoir une totale sécurité
numérique aujourd'hui sur spécialiste dé
répondre mais c'est un très gros
problème très grave qui va aller en
s'aggravant
et de ce point de vue les gouvernements
du monde qui possède des télés des télés
et des telles structures et des télés et
logiciel la ligue doit écourter
attention notamment et donc le cabinet
le cabinet de sécurité les conseils des
cieux les conseils de la défense
français qui serait nouée
merci merci à gilles et on cotise
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste israélien que vous êtes
installé à paris merci beaucoup